Don the director
recently I lost someone very close to me
it doesn't matter who or how but this
person was my life it has caused me a
lot of sadness and almost empty feeling
but like I always say when she lost it
gives you more reason to find your way
sometimes we don't take the most
conventional paths but as long as you're
heading in the right direction I reckon
you'll be okay I've started my journey
and couldn't think of a better story to
share a hump of happiness every
Wednesday what is happiness great
question actually it's possibly the
greatest the dictionary defines it as
the state of being happening but what is
it the answer seems as elusive as
achieving it
we can tell whether or not we are happy
but what is it and how do we achieve it
let me start like this I'm down one of
the seven billion three hundred and four
million nine hundred and ninety two
thousand people on this earth I have a
car a home a TV enough to place me about
the average living standard measurements
in the world but is this what makes me
happy no the media and corporations
consumers we have we go setting
benchmarks on the idea of happiness
controlling the perception of how much
we need to be happy the more you have
the better life is right wrong a
chocolate your favorite CD exercise a
couple drinks likes on Instagram phone
friends ago few girls new t-shirt a
cigarette
to your laptop movie finally YouTube
click take out a book a lot of these
things can make you happy yes but that's
for the now I do believe that being
present is important but first you have
to establish your personal foundations
of happiness within before escaping into
the world of instant gratification that
we live in today I feel it's a large
reason for the increase in worldwide
depression how do I do this you ask that
simple is an equation I came across that
makes so much sense happiness equals
reality over expectation
it comes down to personal perception and
being able to alter that as you grow
from day to day and learn new things
realizing the realities of what you are
surrounded by and not comparing your
life to someone else's that you're
convinced is living the dream and saying
it's unfair they have it so easy but
rather striving for greatness
always be grounded and remain
appreciative of what you have we are all
so different and want different outcomes
for our lives but if you keep searching
for the beauties in the world you will
eventually start living in a beautiful
world before writing this form I didn't
have a conclusion but through this
experience I've arrived at a point where
understand that sadness is vital without
the rain we'll never see the rainbow
being happy is not the easiest road
because there's no destination
you don't just arrive at Avenue happy
and stop moving rather to by loving the
path you chose to travel on and
embracing the journey with open arms and
keep walking forever
thanks once again to green renascent
swapping me after this fault click on
the large screen to subscribe for more
and click on the small screen to watch
another HAMP of happiness see you Bruce
next week